il s'agit en effet d'un travail novateur
dans le champ macroéconomique et plus
que d'un seul rapport à en parler d'une
myriade de rapport puisqu'il faut
ajouter au rapport de synthèse pas moins
de 11 rapports thématiques il s'agit
d'un travail qui joue aussi sur les jeux
d'échelle temporels et spatiales
puisqu'il articule la question de la
transition écologique dans une
perspective de long terme et
internationale et la question plus
concrète de l'horizon 2030 pour notre
pays dans le contexte européen il se
dégage de votre rapport quelques
constats percutants le coût de
l'inaction est supérieur au coût de
l'action la mutation est comparable à
celle de la révolution industrielle mais
plus rapide et orientée par les choix
publics
il va falloir dégager en France un
supplément d'investissement dépassant
deux points de PIB par an d'ici 2030 la
matière est donc riche suscite de
nombreuses réflexions à la hauteur très
certainement des informations
quotidiennes que nous avons sur la
question climatique et environnementale
aussi madame monsieur nous vous écoutons
pour l'introduction préliminaire
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
de nous accueillir je suis très heureux
nous sommes très heureux de voir cette
occasion de vous présenter notre travail
et de dialoguer avec vous je vais
essayer d'être bref dans la présentation
initiale et puis ça nous permettra
d'avoir un temps plus riche pour le
dialogue
donc
le rapport que
[Musique]
nous allons vous présenter
vous avez eu raison de rappeler que il
s'ouvre en disant le coût d'inaction est
supérieur au coût de l'action pour le
climat néanmoins le coût d'action pour
le climat n'est pas négligeable et donc
c'est sur celui-là que nous nous sommes
concentrés alors vous avez aussi rappelé
que
[Musique]
l'enjeu de l'action climatique c'est de
l'ordre d'une révolution industrielle et
le premier graphique qui est là
si on peut le mettre merci vous montre
de 1800 à 250
la composition de l'offre mondiale
d'énergie et je trouve qu'il est
particulièrement frappant parce que le
verre c'est la biomasse le noir c'est le
charbon le gris et le pétrole le brun
c'est le gaz et on voit que si on a eu
cette succession de de vagues et on voit
l'accélération extraordinairement forte
si on vise à atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 c'est à partir des
chiffres de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie
donc
la caractéristique de cette révolution
industrielle c'est que elle est beaucoup
plus rapide que les précédentes et elle
va être guidée par les choix publics et
non pas par la technologie ou par
l'initiative privée
sur le long terme on a de bonnes raisons
d'être optimiste puisque sur le long
terme les la baisse du coût des énergies
renouvelables
et très impressionnante et la capacité à
réorienter le progrès technique
a été démontré en fait par la chute plus
rapide en fait que tout le monde ne
l'avait anticipé
et donc ça nous promet un avenir qui
n'est pas un avenir fait de souffrance
qui est un avenir dans lequel au fond
cette transition écologique sera
l'occasion de découvrir des technologies
qui sont peut-être plus efficaces qui
sont sans doute plus efficaces que les
technologies que nous avions eu jusqu'à
présent et qui reposaient sur la
disponibilité des combustibles de
fossiles néanmoins la transition va être
difficile parce que au fond
elle repose sur trois mécanines
principaux la réorientation du progrès
technique dont j'ai déjà parlé
mais aussi la sobriété et surtout la
substitution de capital des énergies
fossiles alors pourquoi on a mis en
évidence ces mécanismes on a essayé
d'avoir une approche économique de la
transition climatique parce que
la discussion sur ces sujets et
facilement un peu un peu confuse la
discussion elle mélange
la volonté de sobriété elle mélange
quelque chose qui est philosophiquement
intéressant et important qui est le fait
de dire la croissance ce n'est pas le
but de l'activité humaine
sortir de l'obsession de l'accumulation
matérielle c'est en tout cas pour des
sociétés avancées
c'est une c'est une une bonne chose mais
en même temps les discussions sur les
implications économiques de la
transition
elle manquait un petit peu de clarté
donc on s'est attaché à la
clarifier et donc en disant il y a trois
mécanismes principaux la orientation du
progrès technique qui consiste en fait à
investir dans l'innovation investir dans
la recherche de nouveaux procédés je
disais à l'instant que cette
investissement s'est avéré payant
ça consiste à investir dans la sobriété
et la sobriété c'est quelque chose qui
était
pas très très bien défini on a cherché à
donner une définition économique de la
sobriété
qui est la réduction de la consommation
d'énergie qui ne résulte pas de gains
d'efficacité
énergétique donc ça peut couvrir des
mécanismes aussi variés que
le fait de dire on se déplace
différemment se déplace davantage en
vélo on baisse ces
la température dans les dans les
logements on a
un peu on mange un peu moins de viande
où on mange beaucoup moins de viande etc
et tout ça c'est porteur de de gains
du collectif mais ça n'est pas
nécessairement réducteur de l'utilité
individuelle et entre les normes
collectives et l'utilité individuelle il
y a une manière de redéfinir
l'articulation qui est importante mais
le mécanisme principal ce sera la
substitution de capital des énergies
fossiles et de ce point de vue là je
voudrais passer le graphique qui est
juste après qui est un graphique
d'origine britannique et qui illustre à
mon avis de manière très claire le type
de mécanisme qui va être à l'heure
au-dessus de la ligne vous avez les
investissements et en dessous de la
ligne vous avez les réductions de coûts
d'exploitation et ce que vous voyez très
clairement sur ce graphique c'est que
l'investissement au fond au départ
il doit être il doit être consenti c'est
un effort il n'y a pas de rendement
immédiat et quel que soit la manière
dont on le définit mais graduellement en
fait cet investissement va se traduire
en une économie de coût d'exploitation
et ça c'est un mécanisme de générique
que l'on parle de
l'investissement dans les énergies
renouvelables que l'on parle du
nucléaire que l'on parle de la voiture
électrique on parle de l'isolation des
logements ou des bâtiment de manière
générale etc donc
on va avoir on doit faire cette
investissement dans un premier temps cet
investissement n'est pas producteur de
de bien-être
il le devient progressivement mais
contrairement aux mécanisme habituels de
l'investissement contrairement à
l'investissement habituel
l'investissement habituel si on peut
passer la semaine suivante il est
destiné à augmenter les capacités de
production il est destiné à améliorer la
productivité
là c'est pas le cas là dans un premier
temps cet investissement et bien il doit
être consenti pour au fond produire la
même chose
différemment et c'est ça qui est
caractéristique de cette période
intermédiaire de l'ordre de d'une
dizaine d'années ça renvoie au graphique
précédent de l'ordre d'une dizaine
d'années dans lesquelles on va être
amené à investir plus pour ne pas
nécessairement avoir de résultats
immédiats en termes d'amélioration de la
productivité ou du
ou des capacités de production il y a
même un effet qui peut être qui est
probablement négatif sur la productivité
c'est quelque chose qu'on s'est attaché
à chiffrer qu'on a chiffré avec beaucoup
d'imprécisions parce que c'est très
incertain mais qui au total serait de
l'ordre d'un quart de points de
productivité du travail par an sur la
période de transition c'est-à-dire
quelque chose de l'ordre d'une dizaine
d'années un peu moins ou un peu un peu
plus
espérons un peu moins parce que c'est
non négligeable un quart de points de
productivité c'est par rapport à une
tendance productivité qui est l'ordre de
1% par an c'est en gros un quart des
gains de productivité qui est absorbé
par par cela donc c'est c'est ça le
mécanisme et ensuite ce qu'on a essayé
de faire c'est
de recenser les investissements ces
investissements donc qui sont appelés
par la transition écologique sachant
qu'encore une fois que le mécanisme
principal c'est de la substitution de
capital à des énergies fossiles
c'est investissements vous le voyez sur
ce tableau il consiste pour beaucoup
en fait à de l'investissement dans les
bâtiments sur les 60 à 70 milliards
d'investissements totaux on en a une
cinquantaine qui porte sur les bâtiments
donc c'est un effort important et c'est
un effort dans lequel au fond aussi vous
remplacez votre chaudière à fioul ou à
gaz par une pompe à chaleur vous avez à
peu près le même service en termes de
confort en termes de
chaleur
mais vous êtes amené à investir plus et
c'est typiquement ce mécanisme là
dont on parlait tout à l'heure donc je
disais voilà c'est de l'investissement
mais c'est pas de l'investissement au
sens habituel
le reste de l'investissement
c'est
les transports
au fond c'est les secteurs dans lesquels
on a fait peu de choses jusqu'à présent
alors il y a
là-dedans quelque chose sur quoi on
pourra revenir qui est l'hypothèse sur
le développement de la flotte de
véhicule on a fait l'hypothèse qui
aurait moins de deux mobiles en général
et donc c'est pour ça que vous avez un
chiffre négatif
donc parce que il y aura
du développement de d'alternative à la
voiture
individuelle mais évidemment ceci peut
être contesté et c'est ça qui aussi qui
affecte l'incertitude sur les chiffres
de manière générale vous voyez que
l'investissement des entreprises c'est
de l'ordre de 13 milliards donc c'est
pas la partie la plus importante
sachant que évidemment tout ce qui est
le tertiaire privé c'est aussi
l'investissement des entreprises
bien
quelles sont les caractéristiques de
cette transition donc j'ai essayé de la
définir de point de vue macroéconomique
en expliquant que d'un point de vue
macroéconomique la transition c'était
d'investir plus pour produire la même
chose avec ses effets sur la
productivité du point de vue d'un autre
point de vue qui est tout à fait
important qui est le point de vue de la
distribution des efforts la transition
est spontanément inégalitaire pourquoi
elle était inégalitaire parce que si on
parle du logement si on parle de la
voiture on parle d'un taux d'effort qui
est élevé pour les catégories y compris
les catégories de classe moyenne ici on
a donné sur ce tableau
le montant de l'investissement et le
montant de l'investissement en
pourcentage du revenu donc le taux
d'effort pour le logement à la fois
vecteur de chauffage et isolation et
pour le transport et à chaque fois vous
voyez pour la classe moyenne c'est de
l'ordre c'est même un peu plus qu'une
année de revenus donc c'est un effort
considérable pour ces catégories et
comme ça porte évidemment sur d'abord le
logement et le transport c'est c'est un
poids beaucoup plus important pour les
catégories populaires c'est deux fois
deux années de revenus pour les
catégories populaires les premiers
décident de la distribution de revenus
et c'est une fois pour la classe moyenne
donc c'est quelque chose de très
inégalitaire et ça renvoie à la question
de l'impératif d'équité l'impératif
d'équité est très fort en matière de
transition
et écologique et il impose en fait qu'on
est une réflexion sur la manière de
répondre à ce sujet c'est pas un sujet
exclusivement français c'est un sujet
qu'on retrouve un peu partout en
Allemagne en ce moment vous avez eu
enfin tout récemment vous avez eu une
révolte contre l'obligation de changer
sa chaudière
vous avez eu en Suède un mouvement à
l'égard de
la question de
du billet d'avion et du prix de l'avion
et de la capacité qu'on les classes
aisées à prendre à prendre l'avion donc
vous avez un peu partout cette question
de de l'équité qui ressort fortement
et qui est exigeante et pour une raison
simple qui est que les
dans cette affaire on ne parle pas de
l'équité au sens traditionnel on ne
parle pas d'une question simplement de
la répartition du du revenu ou de la
richesse on parle vraiment de la
contribution de chacun à l'effort
collectif pour la survie de la planète
et ça c'est beaucoup plus exigeant j'ai
envie de dire on le dit d'ailleurs dans
le rapport ça s'assimule d'une certaine
manière à la conception de l'équité qui
prévaut en période de guerre ou lorsque
la batterie est en danger et on a là
dans ce genre de circonstances on a une
conception de l'équité qui est beaucoup
plus exigeante donc on est dans ce type
de situation et il ne faut pas négliger
du tout ne serait-ce qu'au nom du succès
de la transition écologique le fait de
d'assurer une juste répartition des
efforts et de montrer que personne ne
s'en exonère d'une manière ou d'une
autre
du coup ça nous amène à discuter de la
contribution que peuvent avoir les
finances publiques
au financement de cette transition alors
ceci c'est évidemment
moins assurés puisqu'on rentre dans des
hypothèses particulières
mais et qu'on peut avoir soit une
contribution directe des finances
publiques soit des approches
d'ingénierie financière pour essayer de
donner accès au crédit dans des bonnes
conditions à des ménages qui n'ont pas
nécessairement accès au crédit ou qui
ont un accès très coûteux au crédit
là ce que nous avons fait c'est de
regarder post par poste comment est-ce
que peuvent se répartir pourraient se
répartir l'effort entre le public et le
privé donc vous voyez par exemple pour
les bâtiments publics c'est 100% public
pour
les tertiaires privés c'est
essentiellement du financement
privé et puis vous avez pour les autres
postes vous avez un partage qui est plus
ou moins important donc on a cherché à
donner un ordre de grandeur
de ce que cela représente au total ça
fait à peu près la moitié de l'effort
d'investissement l'effort
d'investissement total il est je
rappelle entre 60 et 70 milliards on a à
peu près une trentaine de milliards pour
les finances publiques alors comment
comment financer ça et bien il y a
plusieurs solutions évidemment
et
c'est solutions font l'objet d'un choix
et vous allez être amené à un certain
nombre
le premier candidat c'était
évidemment le redéploiement des
dépenses publiques et en particulier des
dépenses brunes puisque
vous avez aujourd'hui 10 milliards pour
l'État dans une acception étroite des
dépenses brunes puisque
par exemple le fait que le fioul aérien
n'est pas taxé n'est pas compté dans ces
10 milliards
pourquoi parce que c'est pas une niche
fiscale c'est pas une dérogation c'est
de droit commun le fioul aérien n'est
pas taxé donc
le 10 milliards de
dépenses Bruna à redéployer et de
dépenses fiscale brune à déployer c'est
c'est une cote inférieure
il n'empêche que vous savez bien à quel
point c'est difficile
de s'attaquer à ça vous savez bien à
quel point le ministère des Finances a
tendance à mettre l'action dessus et
puis face aux réalités politiques
c'est ensuite se poser question et que
le le courage n'est pas nécessairement
là
mais il nous semble que c'est quand même
le premier candidat ensuite il y a
toutes sortes d'autres dépenses qu'on
peut redéployer donc avant de de penser
avant de se poser la question des moyens
financement il y a la question
évidemment de savoir qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire pour pour déployer
il y a des solutions ensuite qui
relèvent de l'ingénierie financière
c'est-à-dire qui relève de la
possibilité de d'améliorer les
conditions de financement de cet
investissement largement pour le
logement ou pour la voiture
qui
permettent des ménages qui autrement n'y
aurait pas accès de d'avoir accès à ces
à ces financements en privé par exemple
vous avez le leasing pour les véhicules
électriques qui est
donc une mesure qui a été
présenté
et qui est mis en oeuvre dont on connaît
pas encore beaucoup le
l'impact de succès mais ça fait partie
d'ingénierie financière et on peut
imaginer d'autres d'autres mécanismes
une fois qu'on a fait tout ça il y a
deux sources qui restent l'endettement
et le prélèvement obligatoire
l'endettement
notre position dans le rapport c'est
qu'il ne faut pas exclure le recours à
l'endettement et que il y a de mauvaises
raisons de s'endetter mais que le climat
n'en fait pas partie et qu'en
particulier le climat c'est quelque
chose qui se caractérise par le fait que
les investissements ont un taux de
retour qui est
assez faible et donc une période
d'amortissement qui est qui est longue
et que donc de ce point de vue là
prenons l'exemple des collectivités
territoriales vous avez des
collectivités territoriales qui vont
investir dans la rénovation des
bâtiments publics dans le changement du
vecteur de chauffage dans les bâtiment
public et cette investissement il va pas
avoir un rendement qui va permettre une
période de quelques années
d'avoir un retour sur investissement ce
retour sur investissement de l'ordre de
la vingtaine d'années voire plus et bien
là-dessus vous avez quand même la
possibilité de construire un véhicule
financier qui permet de dire
voici
si vous
contribuez si vous achetez un titre
particulier pour le financement de la
rénovation des bâtiments public et bien
vous allez avoir un rendement identifié
qui va être en fait gagé sur les
économies qui vont être faites sur les
dépenses de chauffage et de
climatisation
donc à base de combustibles qui existait
donc vous avez quelque chose qui est une
source suffisamment identifiée pour que
vous puissiez là-dessus construire
une approche par par l'endettement
l'autre source de financement c'est ce
sont les prélèvements obligatoires et
vous savez certainement déjà parce que
c'est surtout ça que on a parlé de ce
rapport que nous faisons la proposition
d'un prélèvement exceptionnel
et non récurrent sur le patrimoine
financier des ménages des lieux de thé
c'est à dire du 10% supérieur
alors je voudrais tout de suite dissiper
les choses s'il y a encore des
malentendus il s'agit pas de l'ISF vers
même si c'est comme ça qu'il a été
popularisé il s'agit d'un prélèvement
unique
explicitement non récurrent calibré par
rapport au montant du financement de la
transition écologique et dont l'idée on
pourra y revenir ce serait de
définir pour
les différents
ménages qui seraient assujettis de
définir le montant
de
du prélèvement et ce serait générateur
d'une dette à l'égard de
l'administration fiscale qui ensuite
pourrait être
acquitté selon différentes modalités
il faudrait laisser évidemment de la
souplesse puisque il s'agit pas de
provoquer brutalement les sessions
d'actifs massives
il faut que ça puisse s'étaler dans le
temps il faut que ce soit simplement
équivalent à la fois du point de vue
financier donc du point de vue fiscal
je finis sur le sujet
de la compétitivité le sujet de la
compétitivité c'est un sujet
lourd un sujet lourd parce que les
l'Union européenne c'est au fond porter
aux inventors de la transition
écologique elle a cherché à le faire
avec l'idée d'un pari industriel de
Paris industriel c'était de dire
avec cette transition écologique on va
construire une économie verte on va être
en avance sur le reste du monde
c'est un choix
qui était important courageux c'est à
dire si l'Union européenne n'avait pas
fait ça en 2019 on sait pas où on serait
aujourd'hui
néanmoins il y a des raisons
d'inquiétude parce que ce qu'on a cru
trop facilement c'est toujours les
États-Unis
rejoindraient l'accord de Paris
il le ferait selon les termes qui
correspondent sont à des termes qui
correspondent aux choix européens en
fait ils ont rejoint l'accord de Paris
mais ils ont fait un choix stratégique
complètement différent c'est la
convergence des ambitions c'est pas la
même chose que la convergence des
stratégies et donc aujourd'hui on fait
face à une situation dans laquelle
l'Union européenne c'est
fixé un certain nombre de contraintes
elle cherche à la fois à préserver sa
compétitivité à être championne du
climat et championne de la discipline
budgétaire et à championne du
multilatéralisme il y a probablement des
contraintes excessives
là-dedans en tout cas ça nous semble
inquiétant que aujourd'hui la discussion
européenne soit très fermée sur ce sujet
je crois que je vais m'arrêter là il y a
d'autres choses dans le rapport comme
vous savez
et il y a certainement des sujets sur
lesquels nous aurons l'occasion de
revenir dans la discussion merci
monsieur le Président bien merci
Monsieur piany ferry vous allez voir je
pense qu'il y a pas mal de questions qui
vont vous donner l'occasion de revenir
plus en détail
bon ce que ce que vous dites confirme ce
que je disais tout à dire que
tout l'intérêt d'autres rapports c'est
qu'il y a des d'abord un constat je
pense que personne pour le coup
ne le ni en termes de dégradation
climatique environnementale mystite
réagir il y a les objectifs chiffrés et
puis vous avez des modalités pour les
atteindre évidemment c'est
particulièrement intéressant pour une
commission des finances qui travaillent
sur ces aspects alors moi je voudrais
commencer par les objectifs chiffrés
je reviens sur le coup de l'action
et le coût d'une action est supérieur au
coût de l'action aujourd'hui vous fixez
en gros le destin d'investissement à 70
[Musique]
l'agriculture il me semble que là
justement c'est aussi un domaine qui
d'un point de vue climatique et
environnemental et de la biodiversité
nécessite des investissements alors
ensuite sur les différentes
modalités je vais commencer par des
thèmes que vous n'avez pas abordé mais
qui sont dans le rapport vous annoncez
pour les gens qui viennent un risque de
configuration inflationniste et vous
considérez qu'en conséquence les banques
centrales doivent préciser leur doctrine
conduire la politique monétaire avec
doigté sans même opérer un relèvement de
leur cible d'inflation bon le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que ça ne sent
pas pour le moment l'orientation retenue
dans les hausses des taux directeurs
sont brutales et contenus compte tenu
des garanties indépendance qui entourent
les choix des banques centrales espérer
un tel ajustement temporaire de leur
politique monétaire finalement de
relative pas l'incantation et comment
pourrait-on arriver à une réelle
inflexion de leur part qui reviendrait à
devoir renier ce en quoi elles ont très
longtemps cru c'est à dire on va appeler
ça une politique monétariste
deuxième question
excusez-moi il est également suggéré une
tarification du halles de l'énergie pour
les ménages les plus modestes avec un
quota d’énergie par ménage à coup
subventionné le reste au prix du marché
on n'a pas entendu beaucoup parler de
ses propositions complémentaires donc
j'aimerais bien que vous reveniez dessus
et enfin évidemment je vais parler de la
question
de vos propositions de financement alors
une première remarque vous dites quelque
chose qui me plaît assez je dois dire
parce que je considère que la seule
dette dont on peut mourir c'est la dette
écologique
bien davantage que la dette financière
et vous dites que peut-être faut-il
recourir pour des investissements
un peu plus de dettes bien
le gouvernement prévoit 2,7% de déficits
pour 2027 est-ce que vous avez quantifié
ce poids supérieur de la dette pour
justement financer la question de
l'investissement d'autre part vous
parlez de redéploiement d'autres
dépenses publiques
bon le problème on voit c'est c'est
celui qui affronte le gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qui prévoit des
baisses de dépenses publiques sauf qu'on
entend parler de questions de logement
de santé donc des questions qui peuvent
toucher les questions d'inégalité dont
vous de justice dont vous dites qu'il
faut en prendre le prendre en compte à
partir du moment où on engage une
politique notamment d'investissement de
transition écologique est-ce que quelque
part c'est
imaginable et enfin évidemment ma
dernière question vient sur celle
ce dont on a pu le plus parlé
c'est-à-dire le prélèvement exceptionnel
est temporaire sur le patrimoine des
plus fortunés
je suppose que votre étude avait été
peut-être fait avant les chiffres
révélés par l'IPP sur à la fois
l'enrichissement et ce que j'appellerai
une sous fiscalisation des vraiment plus
riches les milliardaires bon et ce qui
est dans cette étude était intéressante
c'est que c'était pas seulement la
question posée de la justice fiscale
mais c'était le fait que les ressources
du coût disponible était ce quantifier
en milliard voire en dizaines de
milliards alors non alors même que la
cible était finalement réduite en nombre
de personnes est-ce que ça ça renforcé
pour vous le vous tradalys sur une
possibilité
d'un prélèvement exceptionnel et est-ce
qu'on peut pas dire aussi que non
seulement il est nécessaire et s'il
n'est pas mis sur table et ce que vous
voyez une autre solution mais que aussi
il permet peut-être de réduire un peu le
coût carbone et le coût environnemental
ultra riche parce que plus vous êtes
riche plus quelque part et bien c'est
aussi un coût en termes de dégâts
environnemental voilà pour moi les
questions je vais vous poser je passe la
parole au rapporteur général
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup pour votre présentation
merci à tous les deux pour
la grande qualité de ce rapport et
l'apport sans jeu de mots qu'il
est pour la réflexion globale face à un
problème qui évidemment nous nous
rappelle tous à une réalité à laquelle
nous sommes confrontés à laquelle nous
devons absolument trouver des réponses
collectivement votre rapport vous l'avez
dit ne se résume pas à une proposition
sur la fiscalité du capital c'est bien
autre chose beaucoup plus que ça il
vient alimenter notre réflexion
à point nommé il y a la loi de
programmation énergique climat qui
arrive il y a la révision notre
stratégie bas carbone à la révision de
la PPE également qui arrive le plan
national d'adaptation au changement
climatique tout ça sous la houlette du
secrétaire général à la planification
donc on est vraiment aujourd'hui dans
cet élan collectif qui de la
planification
écologique et je trouve voilà que cette
dans ce que vous faites vient alimenter
de manière extrêmement pertinente cette
cette réflexion
qui est intéressant aussi dans votre
document c'est c'est tous les impacts
que vous mesurez et qui sont les impacts
peu réjouissants alors évidemment je ne
parle pas des impacts sur le climat mais
un impact négatif sur la croissance un
impact négatif sur les finances et les
recettes de l'État un impact sur la
productivité baisse de la productivité
et une augmentation également de
l'inflation des impacts très difficiles
à gérer qui peuvent d'ailleurs si on est
fait attention sur les portes attention
garde peuvent avoir aussi des impacts
sociaux et humains extrêmement
extrêmement négatif et je crois que
votre rapport votre travail apporte à
réfléchir collectivement je crois
peut-être c'est le sujet sur lequel nous
devons dépasser l'équivage pour trouver
ensemble des solutions concertées il n'y
a pas de solution simple il n'y a pas de
solution simpliste il y a un ensemble de
solutions effectivement vous en apporter
beaucoup je crois que dans l'intérêt
général nous devons être innovants sur
les solutions à trouver
notre majorité privilégie
les solutions européennes et mondiales
évidemment parce que nous ne voulons pas
rajouter un problème de compétitivité
de notre de notre pays évidemment je
voudrais vous interroger là-dessus vous
étiez plutôt pessimiste sur les
solutions européennes mais voilà quel
type de taxation pourrait être imaginé
au niveau mondial quel type de tactation
pourrait être imaginé au niveau européen
pour le covid on avait accepté l'Europe
avec c'était une dette européenne
supplémentaire et ce qui évidemment pour
nous serait une bonne solution nous
voulons maintenir les prélèvements
obligatoires en France qui sont vous
savez un niveau très élevé et pas
aggraver le sujet donc probablement
faire des des reports certes mais mais
pas augmenté le nouveau de prélèvement
obligatoire et nous ne souhaitons pas
non plus augmenter le niveau de dette
qui nous coûte aujourd'hui 71 milliards
à horizon 2027
sauf si il y a un cadre européen qui
nous permet d'avoir une dette verte sauf
si un cadre européen qui nous permet de
libérer ces contraintes
vous dire aussi qu'on est un peu méfiant
sur les prélèvements temporaires qui
quand on regarde l'histoire des
prélèvements temporaires se pérennis
dans le temps même si je l'ai dit il
faut regarder toutes les solutions et
être créatifs mais on nous voulons pas
évidemment donner un signal négatif au
moment où notre pays retrouve de
l'attractivité et où les investissements
industriels se passent en France qui
permettent également de financer la
transition écologique
j'ai quelques questions
madame monsieur la première c'est le i
Forcilles estime à 84 milliards d'euros
les dépenses d'investissement public et
privés en 2021 en progression
significative par rapport à 2015 et
évidemment par rapport à 2020 qui était
pas une année de référence et est-ce que
vous avez aussi cet ordre de grandeur
aujourd'hui et voilà et dans quel
domaine vidange chiffrage que vous
donnez est supplémentaire par rapport à
ça un effort supplémentaire par rapport
à ça et quels sont les dynamiques que
vous envisagez ma deuxième question
touche les collectivités territoires les
collectivités territoires aujourd'hui
c'est deux tiers de l'investissement
public est-ce que dans votre projection
pour une règle assez simple est-ce que
vous considérez que deux tiers de
l'investissement public de la transition
écologique doit être portée par les
collectivités territoriales l'état
focalisant son soutien sur le retour sur
investissement est le plus faible
évidemment c'est de son ressort en
particulier
l'isolation des bâtiments des bâtiments
publics
troisième question sur le report
des recettes fiscales que vous
préconisez vous anticipez une baisse
logique des recettes sur les exercices
fossiles mais vu préconisé qui est quand
même un report de cette fiscalité sur la
consommation d'énergie des carbonée bon
on voit l'intérêt évidemment en termes
de recettes mais ce que ça n'est pas un
frein au développement de ces énergies
des carbonées enfin
ce sera mon dernier point certaines
économistes appellent à la mise en place
d'une économie de guerre écologique
on appelant à la mise en place de
politique monétaire et budgétaires
clairement expansionniste s'appuyant sur
l'abandon des cibles d'inflation et des
règles d'encadrement budgétaires en
vigueur en Europe
n'est-ce pas en creux ce que vous
préconisez de manière prudente dans
votre rapport merci beaucoup merci
riche je vous propose de répondre à ces
premières séries de questions
la parole je commence complètement du
coup sur les sur les questions sur les
coûts des investissements de façon
générale et plus précisément est-ce que
ça aurait été plus élevé si on l'avait
estimé il y a cinq ans et expliquer un
peu le détail ce qu'on a fait c'est
vraiment regarder entre aujourd'hui et
2030 si on veut réduire 250 millions de
tonnes nos émissions ce qui est ce qui
est nécessaire pour pour réaliser les
objectifs qu'on s'est fixé au niveau
français et européen comment ça se
répartit entre les différents secteurs
environ 50 millions de tonnes dans le
bâtiments à peu près pareil dans le
transport et quelles sont les gros
leviers et on a chiffré les sur quoi
associés associés à ça alors si on avait
fait le calcul il y a 5 ans
les prix des véhicules électriques
auraient peut-être été un petit peu plus
élevés donc on aura eu de ce point de
vue là un coup potentiellement un peu
plus élevé à l'inverse la diffusion
aurait été plus faible donc
on aurait eu un coup plus faible c'est
pas complètement
immédiat de savoir par contre tout ce
qu'on ne fait pas une année donnée ce
reporte donc c'est vraiment si on doit
éliminer remplacer 3 millions de
chaudières au fioul qui est à peu près
le nombre de chaudières au fioul
aujourd'hui par des pompes à chaleur le
coup est là le surcoût des pompes à
chaleur par rapport aux chaudières au
gaz ça conduit à peu près 3 milliards
d'euros par an si on le fait pas
aujourd'hui on devra en faire d'autant
plus demain s'il doit y en avoir zéro
mais si on l'avait étalé sur une plus
longue période du coup par année aurait
été plus faible ça peut être une façon
de répondre sur le transport alors deux
choses on a bien pris en compte les
investissements nécessaires dans le
ferroviaire à la fois pour permettre une
réduction un report scandale du
transport de voyageurs et un report
modal du frais vers le ferroviaire on a
à peu près lors de 2 milliards d'euros
par an alors souvent les chiffres qui
sont donnés d'investissement dans ces
domaines sont cumulés sur un certain
nombre d'années nous on a des chiffres
par an donc ils peuvent paraître plus
faibles et pour répondre à une question
qui a été posée on calcule
l'investissement supplémentaire par
rapport à ce qui aurait eu lieu dans un
scénario où on ne ferait pas cette
réduction des émissions de 150 millions
de tonnes donc une partie des
investissements ferroviaires aurait eu
lieu une partie donc c'est vraiment le
supplément nécessaire pour permettre
d'atteindre d'atteindre ses objectifs
donc effectivement il y a des
investissements dans les infrastructures
de transport de vélo de transport en
commun et en particulier de ferroviaire
fret et et
transport de voyageurs pour permettre un
report un report modal vers ces modes de
transport
sur l'agriculture on a 2 milliards
d'euros dans le tableau qui est présenté
on l'a pas repris mais on a alors c'est
très difficile dans le dans
l'agriculture les trois gros leviers
c'est la c'est l'élevage c'est des
émissions liées de métal liées à
l'élevage c'est tout ce qui est
engrais azoté et puis des carbonations
des engins agricoles c'est assez
difficile de d'estimer les besoins
d'investissement à associer à associer à
ces trois leviers donc on a un chiffre
un peu conservateur de 2 milliards
d'euros par an
sur les banques centrales je te
laisserai répondre la tarification du
halo si
sur la quantification de l'impact sur la
dette de ces investissements on estime
que donc les besoins d'investissement
qu'on chiffre et la part publique qui
est de l'ordre de 30 milliards par an
donc un point de PIB ça fait à peu près
ça fait à peu près 5 à 6 points de pipe
de dette en à l'horizon 2030 et le
double en 2040 alors l'impact qu'on
regarde sur la dette publique on regarde
aussi l'impact possible d'une moindre
croissance qui conduirait à moindre
recettes donc on a aussi on a un impact
total sur la sur la dette plus élevée
liée à ça mais l'impact seul de la prise
en charge publique d'une partie des
investissements c'est c'est de l'ordre
de 5 6 points de PIB en 2030 et le
double en 2040
je vais lier avec la question sur les
l'impact des recettes des pertes de
recettes fiscales effectivement
qui sont assises sur des énergies
carbonées il faut avoir en tête qu'il y
a deux choses il y a une
réduction de la consommation d'énergie
carbonée et le report vers des énergies
des carbonées mais dans la transition il
y a aussi une baisse de la consommation
d'énergie totale assez significative
nécessaire pour faire les objectifs donc
c'est pas seulement le transfert
d'énergie carbonées à des énergies
décarbonées le sujet mais c'est la
baisse en fait de la consommation
d'énergie donc nous on avait chiffré
l'impact sur la dette dans un précédent
travail de la réduction de la
consommation d'énergie totale un carbone
et des carbonée à environ 13 points de
pipe de dette à l'horizon 2050 les
suffrages de
l'administration fiscale et dans ce
rapport on a fait l'hypothèse que d'une
façon ou d'une autre
on inventerait une nouvelle taxe enfin
que ce que ce manque a gagné de recettes
fiscales se récompenser aura titre
d'exemple le Royaume-Uni a commencé à
mettre en place des taxes sur les
véhicules donc à nouveau c'est pas
forcément un report sur des taxes sur
les énergies décarbonées ça peut être
des taxes sur les déplacements sur des
comportements qu'on souhaite décourager
ou simplement on a fait l'hypothèse d'un
taux de prélèvement obligatoire
maintenu
par rapport aux 80 au niveau de dépenses
d'investissement vers aujourd'hui
il y a énormément de conventions nous on
calcule vraiment l'investissement
supplémentaire nécessaire pour faire les
mesures qu'on identifie comme étant les
principales nécessaires pour faire les
réductions d'émissions en raison de 2030
par rapport à un scénario à par rapport
à une situation dans lequel on n'aurait
pas fait cet effort pas par rapport à
aujourd'hui bon
ceci étant dit c'est pas des ordres de
grandeur fondamentalement différents de
ceux d'iforcy qu'on a même si la grosse
incertitude et sur quand même un peu le
contrefactuelle c'est à dire qu'est-ce
qui se serait passé dans ce scénario où
on ferait pas la transition par exemple
dans le transport on suppose que dans le
scénario on ne fait pas la transition
les gens achètent plus de voitures que
dans le scénario on fait la transition
elles sont moins électriques donc elle
coûte moins cher mais ils en achètent
plus au total donc ils dépensent plus en
voiture ce qui fait qu'on a un
investissement supplémentaire en termes
d'achat de véhicule qui est négatif ils
achètent au total moins de voitures à
part des voitures géométrique plus cher
et plus importante mais les dépenses
totales sont plus faibles bon et sur le
partage entre collectivités locales qui
représente deux tiers des
investissements il faut vraiment
regarder ligne c'est-à-dire qu'on a fait
sur les bâtiments publics on suppose que
c'est entièrement les administrations
publiques et répartitions états
collectivités locales surtout ce qui est
soutien au ménage qui est quand même une
grosse partie des dépenses
pas sûr que ça soit les collectivités
locales c'est des dispositifs plutôt du
type ma prime rénov ou autre donc je
suis pas sûr qu'on est le même partage
de terrain tiers que ce qu'on a sur
l'investissement
je vais compléter sur quelques points si
vous me permettez
mais c'est
beaucoup de sujets d'abord un point
général
si on parle de révolution industrielle
si on parle de transformation profonde
ça veut dire que ça aura les
implications lourdes sur un certain
nombre de politiques publiques et en
particulier chez politiques fiscales
donc il y a nécessité d'avoir une
réflexion sur qu'est-ce que c'est que la
bonne fiscalité dans une économie des
carbonée c'est une réflexion pour la
France c'est une réflexion pour d'autres
pays aussi
de manière générale aussi je pense qu'il
y a une notion à laquelle nous sommes
attachés et que nous parlons en rapport
une notion de budget carbone quand on
doit faire une programmation dans le
temps même si l'accord de Paris ne
retient pas cette notion de budget
carbone c'est-à-dire quel est le montant
total des émissions
que l'on
s'autorise d'ici la complète
si elle mérite à raisonner en termes de
budget carbone parce que ça évite la
tentation de repousser dans le temps de
se fixer des objectifs intermédiaires il
y a c'est bien comme ça qu'il faut
raisonner c'est à dire que si on vise à
limiter les températures il faut que le
la notion qui correspond en termes de de
budget de stratégie d'émission de
réduction des émissions c'est une notion
de budget carbone et donc
là aussi ce serait intéressant et
important d'introduire ça dans la dans
la réflexion maintenant sur les
questions que vous avez posées
spécifiquement sur ce président sur deux
choses le risque de configuration
inflationniste la réponse des banques
centrales et la tarification dual de
l'énergie sur le risque configuration
inflationniste
bon c'est très spéculatif mais il me
semble qu'il y a un certain nombre
d'éléments sont réunis
pour penser que on va avoir dans les
années à venir un environnement qui va
être assez différent de l'environnement
qu'on a connu au cours des 10 ou 20
dernières années c'est à dire dans
lequel on se battait pour faire de
l'inflation là qu'est-ce qui va se
passer il va se passer qu'on va avoir de
l'instabilité de la volatilité parce que
on va
assez
systématiquement les simultanément dans
un certain nombre de pays du monde à
aller se tourner vers les énergies
renouvelables vers les matériaux
critiques on va avoir
quel que soit le perspective qu'on a sur
l'offre de matériaux critiques qui
déclare que les désajustements entre
l'offre et la demande vont être très
présents et puis en plus d'un point de
vue interne on va avoir donc à la fois
de l'investissement supplémentaire mais
on va pas avoir des capacités de
production supplémentaire donc on sera
dans une configuration inflationniste
donc
ça nécessite effectivement que les
banques centrales
réfléchissent à la manière dont elles
vont y répondre je suis tout à fait
soutien de l'idée que les banques
centrales
doivent préserver
les acquis de la stabilité des prix
doivent pas
se comporter de manière irresponsable
mais je pense qu'en même temps c'est
important qu'elle réfléchisse à la
question de savoir comment adapter leur
stratégie et par exemple la question de
savoir est-ce que le relèvement de la
cible d'inflation et quelque chose
qu'elle doit considérer dans un contexte
de grande volatilité dans un contexte de
modification importantes des prélatives
je pense que ça mérite une réflexion sur
la question de la tarification du halle
et l'énergie
l'idée est effectivement esquissée dans
le rapport
ils sont consistent à dire bien les
ménages vont avoir un quantum d'énergie
a pris administré et puis à la marge ils
vont payer un prix qui sera plus disons
le prix du marché alors c'est quelque
chose qui se pratique
déjà
en Allemagne enfin il y a eu une
réflexion assez poussée sur cette
question et je pense que en sortie de
bouclier ta richesse ça fait partie des
choses auxquelles il faut réfléchir et
il faut bien faire attention au fait que
effectivement à la marge d'incitation à
économiser de l'énergie d'incitation à
émettre moins elle doit être très
présente nous sommes malgré tout des
individus rationnels et je pense que il
faut pas négliger ce genre de piste quel
que soit les difficultés techniques que
ça présente il y a des difficultés
techniques importantes
merci on va passer aux orateurs de
groupe on va commencer par David Amiel
pour le groupe renaissance pour deux
minutes merci monsieur le Président à
mon tour de féliciter Jeanine Ferri et
Selma fuz pour ce rapport commandé par
le gouvernement dans le cadre de la
planification écologique et qui est je
crois sans précédent à la fois en France
mais aussi dans les pays comparables
j'en retiens pour ma part deux messages
principaux qui confortent la ligne de
notre majorité le premier c'est que la
croissance est compatible avec la
neutralité carbone il y a donc bien une
troisième voie entre le déni social des
uns qui prônent la décroissance et le
déni climatique des autres le second
message c'est que les efforts coûteux et
nécessaires impliqueront une
mobilisation générale et qu'il faut donc
mettre à l'heure de la planification
écologique l'ensemble de nos politiques
économiques d'abord il faudra mobiliser
au plus vite l'intégralité des
investissements publics nécessaires ces
dernières années ont déjà amorcé une
augmentation considérable des moyens il
faudra la poursuivre certainement avec
une visibilité pluriannuelle ensuite il
faudra le faire sans dissuader les
investissements privés en France qui
sont tout aussi indispensables à la
transition écologique ce qui est bien
montré par votre rapport et par votre
propos préliminaire c'est pourquoi nous
ne croyons pas pour notre part à une
augmentation du taux global de
prélèvement obligatoire national mais
cela implique d'être d'autant plus
volontariste sur les autres questions
réorientation de la structure des
dépenses comme des prélèvements en
faveur de la transition écologique
initiative fiscale internationale comme
le président de la République là encore
rappelé la semaine dernière au sommet
pour le nouveau pack financier mondial
distinction depuis le niveau européen
jusqu'au niveau local entre les
investissements verts et les autres
mobilisation beaucoup plus forte du
secteur bancaire et financier question
se pose au niveau de l'État mais elle se
pose aussi au niveau des collectivités
locales et j'étais intéressé par avoir
votre avis sur l'articulation entre les
deux enfin cela devra se faire dans un
cadre économique profondément transformé
le marché de l'électricité ne peut plus
être pensé comme dans les années 2000
nous avons impérativement besoin de prix
plus stable et plus prévisible pour
déclencher les investissements
nécessaires en faveur de
l'électrification c'est l'enjeu des
négociations menées au plan européen la
mondialisation ne peut plus non plus
être pensée comme dans les années 2000
nous devons conduire de père transitions
et réindustrialisation c'est le sens du
redressement de notre compétitivité des
annonces du président de la République
du pacte vert européen de la taxe
carbone aux frontières et là aussi je
voulais vous interroger sur les mesures
supplémentaires qui devraient à votre
sens être mises en oeuvre pour riposter
aux politiques non coopératives chinoise
et américaine merci Monsieur Amiel pour
le rassemblement national c'est Monsieur
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Pisani Ferri madame mafouze tout d'abord
je vous remercie pour votre présentation
qui montre les défis notamment financier
sur la transition énergétique et la
décarbonation de notre pays comme nous
le répétons régulièrement la
décarbonation de notre pays
de notre économie y compris avec la
relance nucléaire nécessite des
investissants massives dans notre pays à
ce titre le projet de loi de l'industrie
verte qui va être discuté à l'Assemblée
nationale dans les prochains jours
apparaît notoirement insuffisant
la question est donc celle du
financement or et votre rapport ne
tranche pas tout à fait sur ce point le
financement ne peut pas ne peut plus
être fondé sur la dette et la hausse des
prélèvements obligatoires je vais partir
de mon expérience de terrain dans le
cadre de la décentralisation le
gouvernement demande collectivités
d'investir massivement dans le fond vert
fond dans lequel on veut faire rentrer
le maximum de projets locaux y compris
la revalorisation du patrimoine dans la
commune de noroy-sur-ourcq sur ma sur ma
circonscription le maire a demandé des
subventions pour la réflexion de la
mairie et la préfecture la réorienté sur
le fond vert alors même que le projet
n'entre pas dans les critères parce par
conséquent j'ai deux questions partant
du principe que l'on demande aux
collectivités d'investir sur du très
long terme pour l'action climatique qui
n'est pas de leur compétences au départ
identifiez-vous des recettes nouvelles
ou de moindre dépenses par exemple lié à
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments ou
à
[Musique]
ou le moindre coût de l'énergie par la
relance du nucléaire qui pourrait être
réintégrée directement au mairies afin
que ces dernières retrouvent une partie
de leur recette qui résulterait de la
transition énergétique pour les
collectivités locales comment
pourrait-on réintégrer directement au
budget des mairies afin que ces
dernières retrouvent une partie de leur
propre recette et peut-on les quantifier
deuxième question pourrait ne
pourrait-on pas commencer à réfléchir à
financement non pas budgétaire mais
monétaire à l'échelle européenne jusqu'à
présent les facilités monétaires de la
Banque centrale européenne était
orientée vers le secteur bancaire et non
financier quel véhicule législatif
possible vous les voyez vous pour les
financer par la banque monétaire de la
BCE transition la transition énergétique
merci Emmanuel Bompard pour la France
oui merci monsieur le Président d'abord
vous remercier à mon tour de votre
rapport et de votre présentation vous
insistez sur le volume important
d'investissement supplémentaire
nécessaire si on veut que la France se
respecte ces engagements climatiques
vous proposez pour cela un recours à
l'endettement public et un prélèvement
exceptionnel sur le patrimoine financier
des 10% les plus aisés suite à votre
rapport le ministre de l'Économie Bruno
Le Maire celui du budget Gabriel Attal
ont écarté tout recours à l'endettement
en disant qu'on ne pouvait pas se
permettre de s'endetter pour financer la
bifurcation écologique je voudrais
savoir ce que vous inspire cette
priorité donnée au désendettement sur
les investissements en faveur de la
transition écologique ou pour poser la
question autrement pensez-vous que l'on
peut se permettre de ne pas s'endetter
malgré l'urgence climatique de son côté
Emmanuel Macron rejette tout prélèvement
national sur les plus riches mais se
prononce désormais pour une taxe verte à
l'échelle internationale cette piste
vous semble-t-elle crédible et l'urgence
climatique nous permet-elle de votre
point de vue d'attendre un accord à
l'échelle internationale de plus
plusieurs études montrent que le coût de
l'inaction climatique sera bien plus
élevé pour nos finances publiques que
les investissements détaillés dans votre
rapport
un rapport de France stratégie du mois
de mars revient en détail sur les
conséquences de notre inaction et selon
les estimations des organisations
internationales le coût de l'inaction
climatique pourrait atteindre 30% du PIB
mondial on est loin des deux points de
PIB supplémentaires d'investissement que
vous évoquez dans votre rapport
pourriez-vous nous dire si vous avez
envisagé de votre côté de chiffrer le
coût de l'inaction climatique j'aimerais
également vous faire réagir sur d'autres
pistes de financement on sait qu'il y a
157 milliards d'euros qui sont versés
chaque année au titre des aides
publiques aux entreprises ne serait-il
pas tant selon vous de faire un grand
inventaire de l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs et de les conditionner à la
réalisation d'objectifs environnementaux
et sociaux de la part des entreprises et
des enfin vous avez parlé d'Europe des
discussions sont en cours au niveau
européen sur la réforme des règles du
pacte de stabilité et de croissance
avez-vous une analyse des propositions
qui sont actuellement sur la table et
estimez vos caleçons de nature à
favoriser les investissements que vous
recommandez ou au faire si elles sont de
nature elle les empêcher je vous
remercie merci Marie-Christine Dalloz
pour les républicains
pour pour financer l'ensemble des des
moyens nécessaires à une transition
climatique vous partez sur deux axes de
pistes financières principales d'une
part le dérapage supplémentaire de notre
dette avec 10 points supplémentaires
alors de PIB à l'horizon 2030 soit 300
milliards de plus au niveau de notre
stock de dette qui est déjà 3000
milliards 15 points à l'horizon 2035 et
25 points supplémentaires à l'horizon
2040 la France figure déjà parmi les
trois pays les plus endettés d'Europe je
crois que c'est il est utile de le
rappeler que faites-vous par rapport à
la soutenabilité de notre dette dans
l'avenir parce que c'est un sujet quand
même pour les générations futures votre
deuxième piste c'est un prélèvement
exceptionnel pour 5 milliards d'euros
donc on est loin de couvrir le besoin en
financement et je rappelle que notre
d'autres prélèvement obligatoire en
France c'est déjà de 45,4 points ceci
étant dit moi je voudrais savoir si vous
avez imaginé d'autres pistes à savoir et
ça me semble une priorité la baisse de
la dépense publique parce qu'on peut
aussi financer de nouvelles dépenses par
une baisse de la maîtrise de la dépense
publique ou éventuellement une excite
taxe ou éventuellement l'élargissement
de la taxe sur les transactions
financières notamment aux transactions
intradées qui sont caractéristiques de
la spéculation et enfin une contribution
éventuellement sur les secteurs
autoroutiers ou le transport maritime et
enfin dernière question et celle-ci j'y
tiens particulièrement vous parlez
beaucoup du véhicule électrique le bilan
carbone de l'utilisation de véhicules
électriques on le connaît est-ce que
vous intégrez le bilan carbone de la
création du véhicule électrique c'est à
dire la conception avec les batteries et
l'or des batteries et l'absence de
filière en France merci merci Pascal le
camp pour le modem merci monsieur le
Président merci félicitations rapporteur
pour ce rapport éclairant pour nous tous
et sur les constantes et les hypothèses
que des moyens en œuvre que vous
proposez dans votre chapitre 4 vous
évoquez les trois mécanismes économiques
pour parvenir à la neutralité climatique
d'ici 2050 parmi eux figure la
substitution de capital aux énergies
fossiles en clair il faudra investir
massivement pour sortir des énergies
fossiles au profit d'un système
énergétique fondé sur les EnR et vous
précisez entre guillemets secondairement
le nucléaire
dans vos recommandations le la question
du nucléaire est très peu évoquée
pouvez-vous nous préciser la place que
vous accordez au secteur nucléaire pour
parvenir à la neutralité climatique
pensez-vous qu'il faille continuer
d'investir massivement dans ce secteur
que pensez-vous du programme financier
auteur de 1 milliard d'euros dans le
cadre de France 2030 pour faire émerger
de nouveaux types de réacteurs comme les
petits réacteurs modulaires projet New
World avec un premier prototype prévu
pour 2030 ou directeur innovants
produisant moins de déchets deuxième
question sur l'isfaire dans le chapitre
10 de votre apport vous suggérez de
financer une partie des investissements
supplémentaires net nécessaire pour
atteindre la totalité climatique à un
prélèvement dédié explicitif
explicitement temporaire qui pourrait
être assis sur le patrimoine financier
des ménages les plus aisés nous vous
rejoignons totalement dans l'idée qu'il
faille trouver de nouvelles sources de
recettes pour nos finances publiques
afin de financer la transition
écologique
dans votre rapport vous n'évoquez pas
l'option d'une mobilisation massive de
l'épargne privée en faveur des objectifs
de neutralité climatiques de pensez-vous
pas que le développement d'une finance
durable efficiente
forfaitaire pourrait permettre de
relever le défi de la transition
écologique
par ailleurs ne pensez-vous pas que la
mesure des prélèvements forfaitaires
exceptionnels sur les 3000 milliards de
stocks d'actifs financiers aurait
potentiellement des effets pervers on
pourrait imaginer qu'un certain nombre
de ménages doivent vendre une partie de
leurs actifs pour payer cette impro
exceptionnel avec le risque qu'il soit
vendu à déménage au moyen financiers
équivalents ne résidant pas en France
car non soumis à cette impôt sur la
fortune que pensez-vous par exemple de
l'idée de mettre en place des mesures
fiscales mieux taxées pour mieux taxer
plus financiers à l'échelle européenne
d'autre part avez-vous eu des réflexions
sur l'option de plutôt réformer des
impôts existants et si oui lesquels
enfin dans votre rapport vous montrer
que le coût budgétaire du financement de
l'action pour le climat reste très
incertain face à cette incertitude le
caractère exceptionnel de l'impôt
proposé même limité à 30 ans que vous
évoquez n'est-il pas discutable je vous
remercie
merci
Michael goulou pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur Pisani Ferri madame mafouze
monsieur le Président Coquerel mes chers
collègues tout d'abord merci pour votre
rapport sur les incidences économiques
de la transition écologique et la
nécessité pour les pouvoirs publics
d'agir en conséquence je veux saluer le
sérieux avec lequel vous êtes appliqué à
démontrer avec des chiffres à l'appui ce
que nous essayons ici d'expliquer à nos
collègues des partis présidentielles il
faut faire contribuer les plus riches
chers collègues des partis
présidentielles c'est bien votre
politique qui est punitive en matière
d'écologie quand vous refusez de faire
participer les plus riches à l'effort
collectif votre rapport votre rapport
renforce nos alertes sur le risque fait
peser sur la cohésion sociale les
exonérations de charge et les
suppressions d'impôts à tout va décider
par le gouvernement votre rapport est
sans ambiguïté sur la nécessité grâce à
cette taxation des plus riches de
redistribuer cet argent vers les ménages
modestes à titre d'exemple le
gouvernement souhaite encourager l'achat
des voitures électriques et la réversion
thermique des bâtiments mais on peut
considérer que c’était quand même un vœu
pieux quand pour le même effort il faut
deux ans de salaire pour une pour les
classes populaires et une petite minute
pour Bernard Arnault et bien sûr toute
la palette entre les deux qui ne leur
rend pas accessible pour beaucoup le
rapport que vous présentez répondez à
une commande de la première ministre
laquelle a finalement renoncé à vous
écouter dès lors les parlementaires que
nous sommes doivent prendre la mesure
des responsabilités qui sont les nôtres
pour engager les réformes urgentes afin
de faire la transition écologique une
réalité immédiate votre rapport nous
porte donc à l'optimisme puisque vous le
soulignez dégrader notre sol de
budgétaire n'est pas une folie mais bien
une nécessité et s'endetter pour le
climat une exigence pour envisager un
futur viable ma question sera donc la
suivante considérant qu'un
investissement annuel autour de 30
milliards d'euros est nécessaire pour
mener à bien cette transition si l'on
n'envisage de ne pas recourir à
l'endettement et c'est le gouvernement
actuel refuse la contribution des plus
aisées quel autre levier voyez-vous
juste un titre d'ouverture par exemple
mais sans vous limiter à cela
soutenez-vous le constat des économistes
de l'IPP que nous avons auditionné la
semaine dernière sur la nécessité de
taxer les dividendes non distribués
stagnant dans les holdings des très très
riches merci merci Monsieur plazard
monsieur Jolivet
merci monsieur le Président Madame
mafouze Monsieur Pisani ferry merci tout
d'abord pour votre rapport et votre
présentation tout à fait intéressant et
documenté nous partageons évidemment les
constats de ce rapport et notamment
trois points essentiels la transition
écologique nécessite beaucoup de moyens
et d'investissement notamment public le
choix entre croissance et climat n'est
pas une obligation incontournable enfin
la réussite de la transition écologique
est possible que si nous mettons en
place des mécanismes équitables ce mur
d'investissement devant nous est le peu
de marge de manœuvre de nos finances
publiques vous conduisent à explorer
trois voies de financement l'endettement
l'augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoires le redéploiement des
dépenses notamment des dépenses
budgétaires ou fiscales brunes même si
vous avez passé vous êtes passé plus
rapidement sur ce dernier point ces
réflexions luminaires faites j'aurais
plusieurs questions la première vous
proposez un prélèvement forfaitaire
exceptionnel de 5% sur l'actif financier
net des 10% des ménages les mieux dotés
ce qui selon vos calculs rapporteraient
150 milliards d'euros à quel niveau de
patrimoine financier correspond les 10%
les mieux dotés ne craignez-vous pas des
effets de bord important si un tel
prélèvement était mis en place notamment
la transformation du capital financier
des ménages visés en d'autres formes
d'actifs non soumis à cette taxation
comme en garantir que ce prélèvement
serait temporaire alors qu'il ne
couvrait qu'une partie de
l'investissement nécessaire à la
transition écologique plus généralement
comment aprèsment temporaire pourrait
financer une dépense qui ne l'est pas
seconde question par ailleurs vous
partez du postulat que la transition
écologique sera je vous cite d'abord
piloté par les politiques publiques et
non par les innovations technologiques
et les marchés pourquoi quel rôle va
jouer l'investissement privé dans la
transition écologique selon vous en fin
dernière question vous constatez de
nouveau je vous cite qu'aucun traitement
de faveur n'est envisagé pour
l'investissement vert en matière de
règles budgétaire européenne est-ce que
vous seriez pour un traitement
spécifique de la dette dite verte je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur Plaza et bah ça pour le
groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
mafouze et Monsieur Pisani ferry pour
votre présentation le 25 mai dernier
vous remettiez à la première ministre
votre rapport et vous y dressiez un
constat clair la transition est
nécessaire elle doit être rapide elle
est possible mais elle est coûteuse vous
estimez à cet égard qu'à l'horizon 2030
le surplus d'investissement public pour
la transition écologique devra être de
25 à 34 milliards d'euros pour atteindre
55% de diminution des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en 2030 contrairement
d'ailleurs au chiffrage die forsy qui
eux se basent sur la SNBC donc des
objectifs nettement moindres par
ailleurs vous notez avec lucidité que le
redéploiement des dépenses néfastes au
climat est nécessaire mais ne suffira
pas alors pour financer cette transition
vous dégagez quelques pistes parmi
lesquelles la mise en place d'une
contribution exceptionnelle sur le
patrimoine financier des 10% les plus
riches dont l'empreinte carbone est
trois fois supérieure à celle des 10%
les plus pauvres vous évoquez également
un nécessaire un l'endettement ces
propositions nous écologistes les
portons depuis de nombreuses années
seulement voilà dès le lendemain de la
publication de votre rapport Bruno Le
Maire balayait d'un revers de la main
ces propositions s'opposant à la fois à
un endettement et à une hausse de la
fiscalité pourtant vous aviez tout pour
que le gouvernement vous écoute vous
avez soutenu Emmanuel Macron dès 2017 et
irresponsable de son programme
économique mais cela n'a pas suffi pour
que le gouvernement sorte de son
dogmatisme économique et prennent les
mesures qui s'imposent au lieu de cela
le gouvernement a vanté le mérite d'une
mobilisation de l'épargne des Français
alors ma question est simple monsieur
Pisani Ferri et Madame Mafouz pensez
vous sérieusement que la solution du
gouvernement la mobilisation de
l'épargne qui n'est même pas évoquée
dans votre rapport pour financer la
transition et pertinente et surtout
suffisante cette solution ne
revient-elle pas à ne financer que des
prêts alors que nous avons besoin de
subventions notamment pour la rénovation
thermique des logements que vous allez
chiffrer comme nous le
enions entre 10 et 14 milliards d'euros
nécessaires
merci
chez le Castellani Polyte
oui merci président merci Madame et
Monsieur pour votre rapport
pas question de remettre en cause
évidemment le nécessité d'intervenir sur
une transition vers l'économie verte le
problème c'est que vous chiffrez ça à
coup de dizaines de milliards et que le
contexte général pose quand même un
certain nombre de questions moi je
voudrais rappeler ce que tout le monde
de sait ici c'est que la dette publique
avoisine 3000 milliards que les taux
d'intérêt augmente ce qui génère une
augmentation aussi de remboursements
d'intérêt que les missions de la dette
pour 2022 a été de 270 milliards quand
même
que le commerce extérieur n'est en aucun
cas un appui mais au contraire une
hémorragie puisque c'est le déficit
c'est
monter à 54 milliards l'an dernier que
ça va pas mieux d'ailleurs cette année
que les besoins sociaux sont
considérables surtout avec le
vieillissement de la population ça ce
sont des en effet que les besoins sont
énormes en infrastructure que sur les
routes la reconversion du nucléaire les
hôpitaux etc voilà que l'ici nous
recevons sans cesse des entreprises
d'État qui nous font un état dans des
vêtements considérables je pense à EDF
SNCF ou autre voilà donc ma question
mois de simples sur question générale
est-ce que le financement de l'action
pour le climat que personne ne remet en
cause je suppose est-ce que ce
financement tel que vous le définissiez
dans votre rapport est-il tenable tout
simplement était un ou alors pour
prendre les choses sur une forme un peu
plus optimiste disons à quel niveau de
croissance puisque la solution elle est
là la croissance économique finalement à
quel niveau de croissance
estimez-vous que cette ce financement
serait tenable voilà merci
je vous invite à répondre
et après j'ai d'autres orateurs je le
précise mais
comment c'est pour les premières
réponses
donc sur les questions de David Amiel
sur l'articulation entre État et
collectivités locales on en a pas
beaucoup parlé effectivement il nous
semble et on dit dans le rapport que
même que l'État s'est fixé des objectifs
en termes de réduction des émissions
c'est moins le cas au niveau des
collectivités
territoriales
certains l'ont fait parfois sans savoir
si leurs objectifs sont trop ambitieux
suffisants cohérents avec les objectifs
nationaux donc
probablement un processus de comme on
l'a fait au niveau de l'accord de Paris
que les collectivités se fixent des
objectifs en face des propositions des
contributions volontaires comme dans
l'accord de Paris qu'au niveau national
on somme pour voir si si c'est suffisant
avec des itérations mais il y a
clairement un enjeu de de même si un
même si deux tiers des des dépenses sont
pas au niveau des collectivités
territoriales et à une grande partie des
actions qui sont au niveau territoriales
donc il y a un enjeu de mobilisation et
d'un petit question des
collectivités locales
sur la question de la
l'articulation entre transition et
réindustrialisation
Jean il reviendra peut-être mais
est-ce qu'il faut des mesures
supplémentaires
par rapport à aux États-Unis à la Chine
il y a déjà un des effectivement quand
on dit que être en Europe les champions
du climat de
la rigueur budgétaire et de la et du
multilatéralisme ça se fait peut-être au
prix de notre compétitivité
on suggère bien que il y a peut-être des
modifications à faire
en tout cas ça doit pas être une raison
de retarder les de retarder des mesures
ou alors si
on considère que et ça rejoint une autre
question qui a été posée que les les
pompes à chaleur sont aujourd'hui
importés que les batteries sont
aujourd'hui importées si on attend
qu'elle soit toute produite en France on
fera pas les objectifs de 2030 de
réduction des émissions donc à un moment
donné c'est voilà il faut juste il faut
juste faire les choix
maintenant dire que certaines aides sont
comme ça a été commencées à être fait
réservé à des véhicules produits en
France etc là c'est peut-être être un
peu plus réaliste effectivement
surtout face aux politiques américaines
sur les sur les collectivités locales en
réponse à Monsieur de Signy
plutôt que de réaffecter des recettes au
mairies notamment
je pense qu'à une des pistes c'est de
permettre aux collectivités qui parfois
ont des investissements rentables dans
l'isolation d'une école on trouvait des
financements auprès de la banque de
territoire de pouvoir s'endetter sur des
périodes un peu plus longues
quand pour faire ce genre de travaux
donc on a plutôt réfléchi dans ce sens
là
surfinancement monétaire je te laisserai
répondre
sur le chiffrage de du coup de de
l'inaction en réponse à Monsieur Bompard
alors le problème c'est qu'il y a
l'inaction en France en Europe et au
niveau mondial donc l'inaction au niveau
mondial son coup on sait bien qu'il est
très très élevé et puis qu'on a même pas
envie d'envisager ce que ce qu'un monde
dans lequel on réduit pas les inactions
du tout les émissions au niveau français
l'inaction au niveau français elle a un
impact plus limité il faut être clair
donc on n'a pas voilà nous on s'est
placé dans dans un scénario d'une part
on a clairement dit d'emblée dans la
première partie du rapport que le coup
de de l'inaction et bien supérieure au
coût de l'action et qu'il y a pas de de
doutes à avoir sur ce sujet et notamment
enfin c'est une période de transition
c'est à dire que c'est dix ans difficile
on a écrit la décennie les difficultés
mais au-delà il y a la perspective de
d'une croissance verte possible c'est
c'est des investissements qui a court
terme produit c'est pas plus sont
difficiles à financer mais pour aller
vers vers une situation qui n'est pas
forcément un renoncement à
la croissance et encore moins au
bien-être il y a aussi tous les co
bénéfices donc on a toute une étude sur
l'impact en termes de bien-être il y a
des coéfices en termes de santé
notamment de la réduction des émissions
qui sont importants à prendre en compte
sur les autres pistes de financement
alors on a parlé de redéploiement des
dépenses brunes notamment on n'a pas
évoqué la conditionnalité des aides
notamment aux entreprises qui a un vieux
sujet
on peut on peut intégrer ça dans le
déploiement dans des pensées ça revient
d'une façon d'une autre à réorienter nos
finances publiques vers nos priorités
comme la disjonction du côté fiscalité
ou du côté des pense si on va vers une
économie des carbonées il est logique
qu'on est une fiscalité cohérente avec
ça et des dépenses publiques cohérentes
avec avec cette économie vers laquelle
on va je te laisserai revenir sur les
réformes du pacte de s'amuser de
croissance
sur les autres pistes peut-être aussi
fiscale alors l'autre les autres pistes
en réponse à Madame DALO je crois sur le
les baisses de dépenses publiques si on
envisage enfin on dit clairement que le
firstb c'est un redéploiement des
dépenses notamment des dépenses fiscales
ou non fiscales favorables aux énergies
carbonées et des autres dépenses donc on
envisageait évidemment voilà on dit on
n'est pas sûr que ça suffise donc il
faut pas forcément exclure si on
n'arrive pas à tout faire par du RE
déploiement de dépenses une hausse
temporaire de l'endettement ou des ou de
la fiscalité
sur la mobilisation de l'épargne privée
et tout ça je te laisse et le nucléaire
sur les alternatives donc en réponse à
Monsieur Boulou
donc 30 milliards d'investissements par
an oui encore une fois si on augmente
pas la dette ni les prélèvements
obligatoires on regarde des alternatives
qui sont toujours le redéploiement des
dépenses notamment des dépenses fiscales
brunes mais pas seulement c'est un peu
ce que je viens de dire
[Musique]
alors c'est une dépense non temporaire
monsieur Plassard si c'est une dépense
temporaire c'est un mur d'investissement
une fois qu'on a des carboné l'économie
c'est pas des choses récurrent après
enfin le sujet la raison pour lequel il
y a un investissement supplémentaire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est
ces investissements dans des équipements
des carbonés ils sont plus chers que les
investissements dans des dans des dans
des équipements carbonés une pompe à
chaleur un véhicule électrique c'est
plus cher tout tout l'enjeu de la
transition et des aides aussi et de la
réorientation du progrès technique c'est
qu'à terme il soit pas plus cher donc à
terme remplacer un véhicule aujourd'hui
les ménages remplacent leurs véhicules
c'est simplement ce surcoût temporaire
et c'est pour ça qu'on a ce mur
d'investissement nous on a chiffré
simplement pas le fait que les gens
achètent des véhicules électriques
globalement mais le surcoût des
véhicules électriques par rapport aux
véhicules thermiques et ça on peut
espérer que c'est quand même temporaire
donc c'est une dépense temporaire c'est
pas une dépense pérenne d'où un
prélèvement ponctuel alors piloté par
les politiques publiques c'est quelque
chose sur lequel des gens ont parfois
réagi effectivement on souhaite pas que
ça soit piloté par les politiques
publiques on constate que c'est une
transition qui est pilotée par les
politiques publiques parce que
contrairement aux révolution
industrielles précédentes elle est pas
drivée elle est pas tirée par des
innovations technologiques on n'a pas
inventé la machine à vapeur c'est pas
pour ça qu'on fait la transition on
décide collectivement de sortir des
énergies fossiles pour réduire nos
émissions et donc c'est bien les
politiques publiques qui ont décidé de
cette transition tout l'enjeu c'est
qu'elle devienne de moins en moins
pilotées par les politiques publiques et
de plus en plus par par l'innovation
et je crois
merci je reviens rapidement sur quelques
points
d'abord sur
la question de la taxe carbone aux
frontières ce qui n'est pas exactement
pour répondre à David Daniel aujourd'hui
c'est un mécanisme de justement carbone
aux frontières c'est précisément pas une
taxe ce Brésil n'ont pas une taxe parce
que la taxe ça voudrait dire en fait à
l'unanimité d'être à l'unanimité donc ce
mécanisme en fait sa contraint les
importateurs ça va contraindre les
importateurs
à se procurer des certificats carbone à
la hauteur du contenu carbone de
importations c'est un mécanisme dont je
crois qu'il faut se féliciter qu'il soit
mise en place
il reste très imparfait on a fait un
travail assez précis et sérieux bon
ça ne couvre pas du tout évidemment la
question de compétitivité à
l'exportation
ça ne couvre pas les importations de
bien
élaboré dans lequel il y a un contenu
carbone et c'est
sa porte quand même essentiellement sur
quelques secteurs aujourd'hui qui sont
des secteurs dans lequel on peut
identifier le contenu carbone des
importations
ceci dit c'est mon avis c'est quelque
chose qui est appelé
à ce
sophistiqué à se développer en tout cas
dans un monde dans lequel une partie de
la planète continue de rester sur les
politiques du passé sur les techniques
de production du passé on va avoir ce
débat de manière lourde permanente
c'est bien que l'Europe soit à
l'initiative sur ce sujet
deuxième question sur
monsieur decigny sur le financement
monétaire à l'échelle européenne
[Musique]
le financement monétaire
monsieur decinin n'est plus là mais je
lui réponds quand même le financement
monétaire il a pu intervenir dans
certaines circonstances notamment dans
les circonstances qu'on a connu
récemment
c'est pas c'est pas la panacée
c'est-à-dire que le financement
monétaire c'est c'est tout de même à la
fin
aujourd'hui
cette en réalité c'est un financement
qui est rémunéré au taux d'intervention
de la Banque centrale et donc
aujourd'hui c'est un financement qui est
relativement coûteux donc il y a pas de
tabou sur le financement monétaire enfin
il faut quand même regarder les chiffres
se dire c'est pas nécessairement la
meilleure des solutions monsieur Bompard
la réaction à la proposition à la
proposition du gouvernement et l'analyse
des propositions européennes
bon la position du gouvernement
moi j'attends de l'avoir pour l'instant
j'ai vu sur tous les impossibilités
c'est non à l'endettement non au
prélèvement
bon
Nathan de savoir et on se rapprochement
assez bientôt quel est le plan de
financement que le gouvernement envisage
si il identifie des sources de
financement par le redéploiement et si
l'assume ceci je n'ai pas de raison de
ne pas être satisfait
la question c'est que il me semble que
si on raisonne sur la durée c'est à dire
on raisonne sur les l'horizons 2030 on a
quand même donc un montant
d'investissement important et il faut
probablement à mon avis
identifier des ressources
plus importantes à mettre en face alors
il y a le sujet dont on a parlé un peu
de l'ingénierie financière c'est-à-dire
de la capacité par des canaux qui sont
des canaux
de type intervention de d'institutions
financière crédible bancaire etc
d'élargir l'accès au crédit pour le
financement d'un certain nombre
d'investissements y compris d'un
investissement des ménages là encore
c'est une idée qu'il faut explorer c'est
une idée qu'il faut explorer en même
temps en se disant bien que
s'il s'agit de créer des véhicules qui
sont
pas dans un nécessairement très
attractif pour pour les ménages il faut
faire attention à ne pas mettre en avant
des solutions qui seraient des solutions
apparentes mais qui seraient pas des
solutions réellement pérennes sur
l'analyse des propositions européennes
le débat aujourd'hui il faut être
honnête le débat européen est bloqué
c'est-à-dire je parle de la partie
réforme des règles de budgétaires il est
bloqué parce que on a d'un côté la
Commission on a de l'autre côté le
gouvernement allemand et donc il y a pas
d'accord qui se dessine sur la réforme
de ces de ses règles et en particulier
il n'y a pas d'accord qui laisse une
place
à un endettement pour le financement de
la transition climatique ça me paraît
pas une position
tenable c'est à dire qu'il faut pas que
l'Union européenne nous soumettent des
injonctions contradictoires d'un côté
réduisez votre dette et de l'autre côté
faites des efforts pour la transition
climatique ce n'est pas compatible alors
je suis pas en train de dire que il faut
lâcher les les
freins et il faut permettre de
s'endetter sans limite ce serait
conscient fait des limites à
l'endettement public simplement je pense
qu'il faut élargir un peu l'espace et de
définir de manière très précise je ne
suis contre par exemple le fait de dire
tout investissement vert est sorti des
règles budgétaires et des normes du pack
de cbit parce qu'on peindra tout en vert
si on fait ça en revanche je pense qu'on
aura besoin d'avoir une définition
précise rigoureuse du type
d'investissement pour lesquels le
recours à l'endettement est possible et
des conditions générales évidemment de
soutenabilité de la dette publique qui
permettent de faire une place à cette
endettement et je pense en particulier à
la question de l'investissement des
collectivités territoriales qui est d'un
investissement
sur des
durées enfin qui a un taux de retour qui
est lent à se manifester donc il faut un
endettement sur une durée de l'ordre
d'une vingtaine d'années il faut trouver
les véhicules pour ça et il faut tout
faire la place à ce sujet mais derrière
cet endettement il y a un rendement
économique donc si un rendement
économique il y a de quoi financer par
endettement donc je pense qu'il faut
définir de manière précise la place
qu'il faut faire au financement par
endettement et est mener le débat
européen sur ce sujet
madame Daloz je crois que c'est le MAP
vous a répondu
mais je pense que le encore une fois
la proposition que nous avons faite
c'est pas une proposition de
[Musique]
taxation permanente c'est pas c'est
l'idée c'est de dire vous constatez à un
moment donné quelle est la valeur du
patrimoine financier
des ménages au-dessus d'un certain seuil
reste évidemment à déterminer on a mis
10% les 10% les plus aisés en termes de
d'illustration vous constatez ça et à
partir de là vous générez effectivement
une dette à l'égard de l'administration
fiscale et vous offrez la possibilité
bien sûr de régler cette dette sur une
durée plus ou moins longue
en sorte en particulier de ne pas
aboutir à une session massive qui serait
qui serait non mais
si vous si vous permettez si vous voulez
y compris que cette
dette soit acquitée au moment de la
mutation au moment de la succession vous
organisez quelque chose qui ne provoque
pas ce séisme financier que vous semblez
redouté je pense qu'évidemment il faut
être très responsable dans ce domaine et
le fait de le faire de la sorte ça
garantit aussi que vous n'avez pas
d'impact sur les comportements puisque
vous avez
une taxation qui est explicitement et de
manière crédible donc non récurrente
monsieur le camp sur le nucléaire
et je vous réponds là-dessus
l'horizon 2030 auquel sur lequel nous
sommes concentrés le nucléaire n'est pas
n'est pas la réponse enfin le nucléaire
et la réponse dans la mesure où le
nucléaire existant
peut effectivement
être
si on peut contribuer à condition bien
sûr que les les investissements de
réparation de de maintenance soit
effectuer mais le nouveau nucléaire
n'est pas une réponse à l'horizon 2030
donc à l'horizon 2030 essentiellement ce
sur quoi nous nous comptons c'est les
renouvelables parce que là il y a une
possibilité de déployer des
renouvelables à l'horizon 2030 et puis
c'est tout ce qui est du côté évidemment
de des invest issements dans la
réduction de la demande d'énergie et ça
c'est important le nucléaire moi je n'ai
pas de de position je suis pas hostile
au nucléaire simplement je ne l'ai pas
compté nous n'avons pas compté parce que
à l'horizon 2030 ce n'est pas un sujet
et donc
notre rapport se focalise quand même sur
l'horizon 2030 pour des raisons liées à
l'urgence
madame
sur
sur l'ISF
très franchement moi j'ai pas de regrets
l'ISF
je pense que ce n'était pas un bon
impôts
c'est un impôt qui dans les travaux qui
ont été conduits ont montré qu'il
n'avait pas de bonnes propriétés
distributives
qu'il t'accès le sommet de la classe
moyenne
mais taxez pas les les plus les plus
fortunés
donc s'il faut reprendre le débat sur la
fiscalité du patrimoine
reprenons-le mais nous ne reprenons pas
avec une nostalgie d'un impôt qui
n'avait pas de bonne propriété
oui la question était sur la
mobilisation du parc
c'est une question sur la liste des fuis
le risque fuite mais si vous dites si
vous êtes non mais si vous êtes crédible
c'est-à-dire si vous dites il y a
aujourd'hui vous constatez la valeur du
patrimoine financier vous déterminez la
le montant du prélèvement et vous
organisez les choses en sorte que ce
prélèvement puisse être effectué sur une
période
comment longue a à la au choix du
contribuable s'agit pas de choix
d'administration fiscale
l'administration fiscale offre un
certain nombre de possibilités de
contribuable déclare que voilà son
attention est de procéder de telle
manière je pense que là vous limitez
beaucoup enfin mon avis vous annulez les
risques de fuite
madame SAS sur l'ingénierie financière
c'est ça je vais la
ça fait partie de
la discussion nous avons une approche
qui consiste à dire que les le soutien
budgétaires
est probablement nécessaire et qu'il y a
des limites à ce qu'on peut faire par
l'ingénierie financière donc
nous sommes assez assez proche de vous
c'est dire que il y a pas c'est pour ça
que on compte en fait
dans les
dans l'équation on compte la nécessité
de pouvoir financer soit parendêtement
soit par l'élèvement parce qu'on pense
que l'ingénierie financière ne peut pas
résoudre l'ensemble des problèmes
merci on va passer aux autres orateurs
pas plus d'une minute par intervention
Monsieur Xavier Rosen
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
permets-toi de vous remercier pour la
qualité du rapport qui nous permet de
faire poser un certain nombre de
questions vous envisagez deux leviers de
financement tels que le recours à la
dette et l'impôt concernant la dette il
y a un risque sur la dette publique de
10 points de PIB en 2030 15 en 2035 et
25 en 2040 le niveau de dette de la
France est déjà très préoccupant
existait un scénario alternatif pour
financer la transition sans faire appel
à la dette est-ce que la solution de la
dette européenne est pour vous
envisageable et qu'est-ce qu'elle peut
avoir un succès ma deuxième question
porte sur la rénovation énergétique vous
signalez l'efficacité de la transition
passera par la rénovation des logements
à la fois chauffage et isolation le
premier poste du coût annuel de la
transition climatique pour les
financements publics à l'horizon 2030 et
la rénovation des logements
est-ce que de votre point de vue il peut
y avoir un frein sachant que par exemple
sur les territoires montagnes vous avez
50% des logements qui devraient rénover
dans les années à venir est-ce qu'un
frein matériel est-ce que vous allez
identifié un frein matériel à la
rénovation est-ce que on a un temps
suffisant pour rénover techniquement
l'ensemble de la partie publique et
privée merci Thomas Cazenave
qui n'est plus là
Émilie bonimat
hanter aussi j'ai senti que vous n'aviez
pas tous les deux exactement le même le
même positionnement dans vos
interventions vous avez indiqué que la
sobriété est une des trois conditions
nécessaires à la transition elle
implique une baisse de la consommation
matérielle vous l'avez vous l'avez
indiqué en tout cas vous semblez
l'appeler de vos vœux on connaît bien
évidemment le lien direct entre
consommation production redistribution
et modèle social français donc la
question que qui est la mienne et la
suivante comment vous maintenez un
modèle social et de redistribution
élevée avec ce que vous indiquez sur la
sobriété et là je fais le lien avec la
relocalisation industrielle en Europe
qui est que l'on partage nous les
républicains avec avec le gouvernement
on a aujourd'hui un déficit de notre
balance commerciale qui recèle
potentiellement bien des ressources avec
la relocalisation et des économies de
carbone est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer parce que c'est parfois ce qui
est dit et je voudrais le vérifier
auprès de vous que nos importations sont
la première source d'émissions gaz à
effet de serre du du pays et enfin sur
l'ajustement carbone aux frontières vous
l'avez indiqué précédemment mais pour
qu'il y ait un impact réel sur la
modification des typologies de
production des économies les plus
polluantes qu'est-ce que vous préconisez
comme modification du mécanisme carbone
aux frontières merci Stella Dupont
merci monsieur le Président merci à tous
les deux pour vos travaux éclair qui
pose très bien je pense les enjeux nous
avons des objectifs de baisse de nos
émissions carbone extrêmement ambitieux
en Europe et en France mais qui dit
objectif ambitieux dit modalités de mise
en œuvre et financement qui doit l'être
qui doivent être également vous chiffrez
la dépense à 60 milliards d'euros
chiffrage globalement admis qui ne fait
pas débats qui ne fait plus débat et ça
c'est une avancée je pense dans notre
réflexion l'enjeu du financement lui
fait débat et on ne peut pas les Luder
il y a urgence à agir et donc urgence à
planifier et à financer des
investissements de la France et de
l'Union européenne on a la loi de
programmation climat énergie toute
proche je pense que nous avons besoin
d'une loi de programmation de
financement également de ces
investissements on peut avoir les plus
belles intentions et les plus belles
ambitions mais sans financement on ira
nulle part donc ni s'endetter ni
augmenter les prélèvements obligatoires
je pense que si on part de ce principe
on ne fait rien assurément donc il faut
rester ouvert pour construire une
programmation crédible de la France et
de l'Union européenne pour avoir un
financement s'assurer d'un financement
de tous ces investissements et ma
question c'est dans quelle mesure le
prélèvement exceptionnel mal nommé ISF
vers
ne ferait-il pas obstacle à la stratégie
du gouvernement dans sa politique
économique de l'offre et de baisse de la
fiscalité merci Emmanuel Lacresse
merci monsieur le Président de mes
émissions des rapporteurs
les objets que sur lequel sont penchés
votre étude dans l'horizon 2030 c'est
les batteries les conceptions les fixés
énergétiques la circularité la
production d'énergie durable
l'électrification en fait alors même si
effectivement à l'horizon 2030 le
nucléaire n'est pas un enjeu massif il
faut d'ici là quand même maintenir le
parc reconstituer une industrie une
filière notamment pour la maintenance
mais aussi pour la construction du
nouveau nucléaire et des EPR et les
rapporteurs du budget spécial à
l'énergie sont penchés sur cette
question et ce sont interrogés dans les
termes de votre rapport c'est à dire
quelle est la clé de répartition entre
le contribuable d'un côté et le
consommateur d'énergie de l'autre il est
notable que la Commission de régulation
de l'énergie dans quelques mois va
devoir fixer le prix de long terme de
l'énergie électrique et que il faudra
décider si EDF doit porter une masse de
prêt considérable ou si au contraire il
faut trouver des modes de financement et
j'aimerais votre regard sur sur cela
parce que c'est un enjeu déterminant
pour la supportabilité par nos
concitoyens de l'effort que vous
décrivez merci
merci Benoît Bournet
merci monsieur le Président Madame
Monsieur les rapporteurs d'abord vous
remercier vraiment pour ces travaux
enfin ça a été dit mais on peut le
répéter parce que c'est vraiment
extrêmement utile moi ce que je trouve
très intéressant dans le rapport c'est
que vous
documentez objectivement le lien qui a
entre rien industrialisation et
transition écologique et que personne
ici ne conteste le fait que il faut
faire cette transition écologique et la
financer moi la question que je me
posais c'est est-ce que vous avez
travaillé ou une connaissance ou pris
connaissance des travaux d'Alexandre
Rambaud et d'Hervé j'ai beau sur la
comptabilité écologique sont des
chercheurs d'AgroParisTech et qui nous
invite à une échelle peut-être plus
micro dans la comptabilité ça nous
intéresse ici à la évidemment à la
commission des finances de prendre en
compte les coûts écologiques non payés
intégrer le coût des actions nécessaires
dans le dans le budget c'est pas un
exercice de budget vert qui consiste
simplement à taguer mais c'est vraiment
de de faire rentrer dans la méthodologie
de comptabilité les actions climatiques
je vous remercie merci
Fabien des Philippot merci monsieur le
Président il y a un sujet un peu laissé
de côté que je voulais aborder quand on
parle des incidents économiques de
l'action pour le climat on entend parler
dans beaucoup de de rapports sortis
récemment prise de parole aussi de
ministre du président de la nécessité de
réduire notre consommation d'eau ça aura
un impact économique certains si c'est
fait de la de la sorte sur nos
industries sur notre agriculture or moi
on produit plus on importe donc la
question que je voulais vous poser
c'était celle de la stratégie qui est
celle de notre pays en matière d'usage
des eaux grises on apprend aujourd'hui
qu'à Barcelone est bien aujourd'hui la
moitié de l'eau qui sort du du robinet
et de l'eau recyclée c'est 0,2 % pour
l'instant en France il y a beaucoup
d'usages qui pourraient quand même être
permis même si encore beaucoup de
verrous lég islatives dans notre pays
sur l'usage des eaux grises mais en
matière économique en matière domestique
en matière aussi de réintroduction dans
les nappes phréatiques parce que c'est
le cas c'est le cas en Espagne sans que
cela pose de problème et donc je voulais
avoir votre approche sur le sur le sujet
parce que si on a une approche
malthusienne nos industries nos
agriculteurs ont le pays au prix fort et
de toute façon on sera obligé d'importer
davantage merci Christina RIC
oui un récent rapport d'une de synthèse
de l'Académie des technologies qui s'est
tenues en 2022 vient d'être publiés qui
fait état de six constats dont le
quatrième paraît extrêmement intéressant
sur la sobriété nécessite une approche
globale combinant comportement
individuel mesure systémique
infrastructures réglementation et
évolution de la structure de nos
consommations et le sixième de ce
constat c'est plutôt une recommandation
il faut agir sans tarder donc ma
question c'est de savoir si parmi les
éléments enfin en tout cas les sans
chantiers dans lesquels apporté cette
académie des technologies énergies
mobilité habitat industrie matériaux
agriculture infrastructures etc vous
avez d'autres champs d'action sur
lesquels vous semble que la sobriété
puisse être mise en oeuvre et enfin dans
ce que nous sommes à la veille de du PLF
2024 est-ce que nous avons posé la
question de qu'est-ce qui se serait
passé si nous avions agi avant d'interia
5 ans et est-ce que vous avez évalué
qu'est-ce qui va se passer si nous
n'agissons pas dès 2024 par rapport à
vos prévisions de 2030
merci est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions
non
je suis désolé sur la première question
j'étais j'avais un aparté avec le
président de monsieur va bien compris je
te laisse
pour la réponse à Madame Bonneau
question
importante mais question qui me semble
je suis pas sûr que la
sobriété met en cause fondamentalement
notre modèle social vous savez social il
a il a existé quand même à travers pas
mal de transformation
il a il s'est maintenu
il s'est développé
malgré des transformations importantes
et je crois que le la sobriété c'est un
nouveau défi et c'est à nouveau défi qui
nécessite des réponses des adaptations
du modèle social mais c'est pas quelque
chose qui ne met fondamentalement en
cause sur la question du la source des
émissions
les importations ce n'est pas la
première chose des émissions de loin il
y a un écart effectivement entre
l'empreinte carbone et les émissions
territoriales mais c'était car il est il
est assez limité alors j'ai pas l'ordre
de grandeur exactes je dirais de l'ordre
de 20% ou des choses comme ça mais 80%
c'est quand même des émissions
territoriales
pour
cela Dupont alors moi je
rebondis sur la suggestion en fait de
lier
programmation climat et programmation
financière je pense que c'est le cœur de
la question que vous posez et je pense
que c'est très important c'est à dire
qu'on a besoin d'allonger l'horizon et
on a besoin de mettre en cohérence la
programmation des finances publiques et
la programmation
de l'action climatique
donc ça c'est un les outils sont à
construire c'est à dire que
effectivement on a l'horizon qui mène
l'horizon de l'action climatique c'est
un horizon long
et et cette mise en cohérence est
indispensable elle est indispensable
pour l'instant on a l'horizon 2024 on a
le PLF 2024 mais on sait pas très bien
ce qu'il y a au-delà je pense que c'est
très important de donner de la
visibilité et de de programmer
l'ensemble des réflexions et l'ensemble
des actions sur sur les finances
publiques au-delà donc
cette c'est quelque chose qui va sans
doute vous occuper pendant pas mal de
temps
monsieur
la crèche
poser un très bonne question
c'est-à-dire
qu'elle est comment est-ce qu'on va
répartir la charge de l'investissement
dans le nouveau nucléaire entre
le l'investissement entre l'endettement
de
DDF et
l'augmentation du prix de l'électricité
je dois dire que je ne connais pas le
dossier suffisamment pour vous répondre
de manière précise et en plus je suis
pas sûr que à ce stade on est bien
arrêté les choses
monsieur murmet
[Musique]
la comptabilité écologique c'est quelque
chose qui doit se développer et je
voudrais dire que moi j'étais frappé
dans les travaux préparatoires qu'on a
fait
de voir à quel point maintenant c'est
accepter par les comptables nationaux
l'idée d'avoir
un PIB
disons nette des dommages causés à
l'environnement c'est une idée qui est
aujourd'hui acceptée par la communauté
des comptables nationaux
ça veut pas dire que c'est facile à
faire ça veut dire qu'il faut mettre un
prix sur les émissions ça veut dire
qu'il faut mettre un prix sur les
dommages à la biodiversité etc mais
disons que le virage conceptuel est fait
et ça me paraît très important
[Musique]
du coup sur la première question
sur les risques de frein matériel
notamment sur le
sur la rénovation énergétique liée au
fait que c'est déjà un des premiers
postes de dépenses publiques oui enfin
il y a des risques de difficultés de
déploiement c'est clair et ça amène à
enfin vraiment réfléchir
et à commencer aussi le mouvement
rapidement peut-être revenir aussi un
tout petit peu sur se briété je pense
que comme Jean Pisani ferry il a dit la
sobriété ça implique pas une baisse de
la consommation matérielle réduire la
température ça implique une baisse de la
consommation d'énergie ça c'est sûr mais
limiter le gaspillage en étant en
éteignant son ordinateur la nuit réduire
la température où aller vers le vélo ça
permet éventuellement de réduire sa
facture énergétique et de consommer plus
autre chose donc c'est pas du tout le
lien entre
sobriété et consommation totale et
production et production de richesse
c'est pas une évoque si on organise les
villes différemment pour que les gens
aient moins besoin de prendre la voiture
ils consomment moins d'essence qu'on
importe donc ça nous rend collectivement
plutôt touristes donc c'est pas du tout
aussi simple que ça donc on a tout une
réflexion alors il faut penser la
sobriété c'est pas complètement simple
parce que dans sobriété il y a l'idée de
surconsommation qui est pas quelque
chose de très de très intuitif mais on
voit bien que non seulement ça peut ne
pas réduire l'utilité des gens de la
sobriété mais en plus ça peut ne même
pas réduire la consommation et le piment
en fait
et ça répondait aussi à la question dans
quelle chambre c'est beaucoup dans à
l'horizon 2030 c'est beaucoup dans le
champ de la mobilité quand même qu'on a
une possibilité d'action de sobriété
c'est Lana que parce que c'est du report
modal vers le vélo c'est et dans le
champ de l'agriculture aussi et sur le
PLF 2024 j'avais envie de dire
nous n'agissons pas dès 2024 la question
a été posée par Madame Arrighi
ben ça sera juste
l'investissement qu'on n'aura pas fait
en 2024 il faudra le faire en 2025 donc
c'est la marche est plus haute ou bien
sinon à la fin si on prend le
remplacement des des chaudières au fioul
par des pompes à chaleur si on veut
remplacer 3 millions de chaudières au
fioul ou 3 millions de chaudières à gaz
qui est à peu près un quart des chadière
à gaz d'ici 2030 qu'on n'aura pas fait
en 2024 faudra le faire en 2025 au total
les deux mesures font à peu près 10
millions de tonnes de réduction des des
émissions si on en a remplacé que la
moitié est pas toutes les chaudières au
fioul mais on aura fait 5 millions de
tonnes ou sinon il faudra rattraper des
années d'après j'ai envie de dire après
c'est pas c'est pas que des dépenses
publiques mais sur les sur le calendrier
de l'investissement c'est clair que
bien merci j'étais en vous écoutant je
me disais que il faudrait qu'on soit
capable même à la louche avec une étude
de mesurer évidemment le coût de
l'inaction parce que le coût de l'action
on le voit il est de 70 milliards alors
les uns et les autres on a des réponses
le l'inaction à partir de chiffre pas il
reste
il reste dans l'imaginaire quelque part
et de ce point de vue là je pensais je
pensais à vous parce qu'elle legrange je
vais vous l'envoyer une thésarde la Cour
des comptes qui a été lauréate de lundi
que j'étais assisté à l'arbitre et le
rire qui a travaillé par contre ne
serait-ce que sur le coup pour le la
production céréalière des changements
climatiques dans les années à venir et
c'est énorme c'est énorme c'est bon et
je me dis que ça il faudrait qu'on
arrive à faire ce travail ce qui après
mesurer les conséquences d'une action
voilà je trouve merci beaucoup oui
allez-y allez-y je vous pour vous
répondre là dessus et pour
aller dans votre sens moi j'étais frappé
dans ce travail
un moment au départ on s'est dit on va
travailler sur
l'atténuation et on va laisser de côté
la question d'adaptation et des coûts
des dommages et puis on s'est dit non
c'est pas possible et donc on a aussi
bien travaillé là-dessus et on a
découvert que en fait on savait
extrêmement peu de choses
c'est à dire qu'il est au niveau
français on a
on a recensé des des travaux on a mais
mais on a une très loin d'une
quantification
et on est donc très loin de mesurer avec
précision le coût d'une action et ce qui
est vrai au niveau français est assez
vrai au niveau international aussi bien
je trouve que c'est bien de que vous
fassiez l'honneur de confirmer que
j'avais raison c'est une bonne
conclusion de cette audition monsieur
Pisani Ferri en tout cas tous les deux
merci on était très content de
seditionner c'était un vrai une vraie
volonté collective
chers collègues on se retrouve demain
jeudi à 29 juin à 11h pour ce qui sera
derrière union de la commission des
finances de cette session ordinaire
n'aura d'autre ensuite mais pas de la
session ordinaire au cours de laquelle
nous entendons monsieur Moscovici sur le
rapport sur la situation et les
perspectives des finances publiques
publiées par la Cour des comptes merci
beaucoup